(applause)
- So, the Pandemic really
changed family life this year.
Jessica, did you still
get to do any family trips
over the summer?
Did y'all do anything?
- We like,
yes.
We did two road trips,
which we've never done one before this.
I don't even think Cash and I
ever took a road trip
prior to having kids.
Yeah, we've never done this one before.
And we, (laughs)
- (laughs) Sounds like
it went smoothingly well.
- Drove to Wyoming.
Yeah, we drove to Wyoming.
We stopped in Zion.
It was 110 degrees.
We were driving my brother's RV.
He did let us borrow it.
It did not have air conditioning.
It was 110 with no air conditioning.
Sharing a bed with our toddler,
who has never slept
outside of a crib before.
And all my kids got very vomitous,
carsick the entire time.
And when we landed in Zion at 11:00 PM,
which would they,
they were like,
it's two hours past the time
anyone is allowed to pull in,
because it's lights out,
this, you know, RV, whatever.
And we're like, okay well anyways,
we have nowhere else to go.
So we're just gonna go here
and park the thing,
and Cash backs in.
And everyone's just like hot,
and they wanna get out,
and we're starving.
We haven't eaten in 10 hours.
And right when I take the
baby out of his car seat,
he vomits in my mouth and my eyes.
(gasps)
(Audience murmurs)
And everyone in the RV goes "Eew!"
including Cash,
and run out.
And so I'm blinded
by warm acid vomit.
- (laughs) Oh my God.
- And it's in my (mumbles)
"Ah, guys! Guys!"
And he's covered in it.
(laughs)
(Audience laughs)
And so, I, it's like my mom mind,
knows how to like take
off his clothes quickly,
'cause I didn't want him
like running around the,
getting the vomit all over the RV obvie.
(laughs)
And I like wanted to keep it contained.
And then this fool jumps out the RV,
in his diaper,
(laughs)
and starts chasing frogs,
like nasty, wild toads or frogs.
And this is like our first
time out of our house in,
sitting in four and a half, five months.
- Huh?
- And then he starts going
to other people's camps!
COVID camps!
(Audience laughs)
I'm like, the baby's gonna get COVID.
And I'm like, still have
the vomit everywhere.
I'm like, what is happening?
So this is like my, our first night,
on our first road--
- That's a movie.
That's the greatest scene from a movie.
- It was the worst.
It was my nightmare.
It was my actual nightmare.
But then somehow, three weeks later,
I'm like, "Let's do it again".
(laughs)
And so we forgot,
went up to Bend, Oregon,
which was beautiful.
They have, you know, bicycles,
and very nice there.
But then we accidentally were driving,
and this time we did a Sprinter van,
and we accidentally drove the kids into
a couple of the fires in Napa by accident.
So that was, that was that.
- (laughs) Oh my God.
- (chuckles) Should we
like just feel like,
we lost cell phone service.
It was just a,
it was a situation.
It was a situation.
- Oh my God!
- So yeah, my kids might
have PTSD from road trips.
They may not ever (mumbles) (laughs)
- They're gonna be like, "I'm out."
- (laughs) They might be scarred for life.
(upbeat music)